ganz genau uns erreichen breaking news
die regierung schlägt nämlich alarm weil
der pflegeversicherung ihr droht die
zahlungsunfähigkeit bild ist gerade ein
brief des
bundesfinanzministeriums an den
bundestag zugespielt worden darin warnt
eine staatssekretärin wenn nicht anfang
oktober eine milliarde euro fließt droht
der pflege die zahlungsunfähigkeit
außerdem kann nur durch diese
überweisung vermieden werden dass der
beitragssatz zur sozialen
pflegeversicherung für 2021 erhöht wird
warum die gelder plötzlich so knapp sind
der mehrbedarf bei der pflege wegen der
korona krise und bei uns im studio ist
unser politik chef jan schäfer jan 40
ist kein geld mehr da das richtig ist
nicht ganz verwunderlich es geht um
diesen brief zwei seiten der heute
morgen ausgestellt wurde von der
staatssekretärin im
bundesfinanzministerium bettina hagedorn
ist verschickt worden an den chef des
haushaltsausschusses und damit an alle
ausschussmitglieder der
haushaltsausschuss ist das gremium das
das geld verwaltet für den für den
bundestag und es gab gestern abend
bereits ein vor briefing jetzt der brief
also darin heißt es eine milliarde
müssen bis zum 15 oktober an die
pflegeversicherung gezahlt werden wir
haben gerade schon auch gehört ansonsten
drohen einzelnen pflegekassen in dieser
pflegeversicherung offenbar die pleite
die zahlungsunfähigkeit wie realistisch
realistisch ist das eine milliarde das
ist absolut richtig wir reden über einen
bundeshaushalt der aber deutlich höher
liegt wir legen überreden über 460
milliarden insofern ist das geld
natürlich das ist brisant zu hören dass
offenbar auch die pflegeversicherung
sich nicht mehr selbst mit ihren
beitragsmitteln alleine finanzieren kann
sondern jetzt auch aus dem
bundeshaushalt unterstützt werden muss
bei der rente ist es bereits so über 100
milliarden wir wissen es bei der
krankenversicherung ist es auch so bei
der gesetzlichen und als dritte
sozialkasse kommt jetzt die
pflegeversicherung hinzu obwohl die
beiträge erste 2 910 gestiegen sind zum
ersten januar 222 auch für kinderlose
nochmal steigen werden der
pflegeversicherung geht das geld aus
akuten pleitegefahr das heißt das für
alle pflegebedürftigen
für die pflegebedürftigen heißt es also
dass die milliarde mutmaßlich gezahlt
wird es geht erstmal so weiter wie
bisher
aber insgesamt muss man natürlich sagen
system ist offenbar dramatisch
unterfinanziert also entweder sind die
beiträge zu niedrig das hat ein anschein
sonst würde es jetzt keine drohende
pleite geben und die zuschüsse aus dem
bundeshaushalt sind zu gering oder die
leistungen die erbracht werden sind halt
zu teuer aber wir wissen auch wie es in
einzelnen pflegeheim aussieht von daher
ist wahrscheinlich der punkt nicht dass
es zu viel leistung gibt sondern eher
dass es zu niedrige beitragssätze zu
wenig finanzierung gibt